صحيفه عن الخارجيه الامريكيه عزم الاداره
الامريكيه فرض عقوبات على اطراف القتال في
السودان لردعها وكانت الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي والامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي قد نالت اندلاع
المواجهات المسلحه في البلاد ودعت لوقفها
فورا ودعت الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
لاعتماد الحوار لحل الخلافات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف بدات كيف بدات
تعامل الاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه مع
انزلاق السودان نحو المواجهه المسلحه بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع على نحو فاق
مازمات البلاد على ماذا ستقوم مشاورات
واشنطن مع شركائها والى ماذا قد تفضي والى
اي مدى تساهم العقوبات على اطراف القتال
في ايقاف النزاع الدامي بينها الى ماذا قد
يتطور التعاطي الاقليمي والدولي مع
الاحتمالات التي يمكن للمشهد السوداني ان
يتطور نحوها واي تاثير للتدخلات الخارجيه
في ذلك
[موسيقى]
يكافح المجتمع الدولي ويسابق الزمن لايقاف
القتال الدائري في السودان وحمله اطرافه
على الحوار واذا كانت لجميع الاطراف
والهيئات الدوليه قد دانت اندلاع
المواجهات فقد مرت واشنطن الى التفكير في
فرض عقوبات لعلها توقف نزيف الدماء عند
حده صحيفه نقلت عن الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
واشنطن تتشاور مع شركاء الاقليميين وغيرهم
بشان تطورات الوضع في السودان وزير الدوله
البريطانيه للشؤون الافريقيه اكد بدوره ان
لندن تعمل عن كثب مع الحلفاء لضمان وقف
الاشتباكات من جانبه قال الاتحاد الاوروبي
ان القتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
في السودان يهدد بزعزعه الاستقرار
الاقليمي واعرب الاتحاد الاوروبي عندها
دعم جهود تقودها الامم المتحده والاتحاد
الافريقي والهيئه الحكوميه ايجاد تقود
لانهاء القتال في السودان بين ان انتهاء
النزاع المسلح بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع يعتمد
على دعوات التعقل على استماعهما لدعوات
التعقل ووقف الاحتراب والذهاب لمفاوضات
تنهي
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الى السودان من نيويورك عبد الحميد صيام
الخبير في شؤون الامم المتحده اهلا وسهلا
كيف بدا لك تعامل مجتمع الدولي مع هذه
الازمه في السودان واصولها الى اندلاع
المواجهات العسكريه على هذا النحو في
شوارع الخرطوم
اعتقد انه من منظور واشنطن فان تركيز هو
على مستويين حاليا اولا محاوله التوجه
مباشره الى طرفين
على توقف القتال او على الاقل وقف اطلاق
نار ولو لفتره قصيره اما النقطه الثانيه
فهي العمل على خيارات من اجل اخراج
العاملين في السفاره الامريكيه من البلاد
هاتان هما الاولويتان بالنسبه الى واشنطن
حاليا ابعد من ذلك بالنسبه الى العواصم
الاوروبيه يبدو ان
السلطات هناك ايضا قلقه من هذا النزاع من
هذا الازمه في الخرطوم التي
ليست تتطور الى ما هو افضل بل تتدهور وان
يركزون
اقل على موضوع المسار والعمليه السياسيه
واكثر على امن طواقم السفارات والسلك
الديبلوماسي استاذ عبد الحميد صيام تفاعل
المجتمع الدولي وتجاوبه مع ما حدث في
الخرطوم ما حدث في السودان هل تعتقد انه
كان
بمستوى خطوره هذا الحدث الجلل
شكرا عثمان اولا كل عام وانت بخير وانت كل
عام والمشاهدين الكرام بخير
الحقيقه ان المجتمع الدولي فورا تحرك
عندما بدات الاشتباكات الاسبوع الماضي كان
هناك لقاء فورا في مجلس الامن صدر بيان عن
المجلس يطالب الاطراف بوقف القتال فورا
تحرك الامين العام واتصل بالاتحاد
الافريقي والاتحاد الاوروبي والجامعه
العربيه واقام شبكه من الاتصالات واجتمع
مجلس الامن كذلك يوم الخميس الماضي في
جلسه مغلقه استمع فيها ايضا الى تقرير من
السيد فولكرز الذي قدم تقريرا عن خاصه عن
الاحوال المدنيين وصعوبه ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه
وتحدث عن جهوده كذلك لمحاوله احتواء
النزاع وطلب هدنه على الاقل كانت البدايه
طلب ثلاث ساعات مع ساعات الغروب لاعطاء
الصائمين فرصه ثم طلب الامين العام ايضا
في نداء وجهه يوم الخميس
طلب 24 ساعه او ثلاثه ايام خلال ايام
العيد لكن تجاوب الاطراف لم يكن
متعاونين مع هذه النداءات ويعني الامين
العام جمع في مجلس الامن كل الاطراف
الاتحاد الافريقي والاتحاد الاوروبي ودول
معنيه والجامعه العربيه الكل هناك اجماع
حقيقي داخل المجموعه الدوليه يطالب
الاطراف بوقف اطلاق النار فورا لان هناك
ماساه انسانيه 15 مليون سوداني بحاجه الى
مساعدات ثلاث ملايين وثمانمائه الف مشرد
في السودان بحاجه ايضا الى مساعدات النقطه
المهمه التي توصل اليها المجتمع وهذا ما
قاله السيد
عندما التقى مع الصحفيين قال هذه مشكله
الصراع على السلطه يعني التدخل الخارجي او
المناشدات لا تجدي لان هناك من يريد ان
يفرض سيطرته على الاخر هؤلاء مكونان كان
يعملان مع بعض ضد المكون المدني لكن الان
الخلاف بين مكونين عسكريين نعم مكونين
كرييين نعم وكل هذه الجهات دعت الى هدنه
الى وقف العنف هذا لم يحدث حتى الان زيدسن
الولايات المتحده ادانت العنف دعت الى وقف
الاطلاق النار وكذلك فعل الاتحاد الاوروبي
ولكن على الصعيد العملي فعليا هل كان لذلك
اي صدى على الطرفين المتصارعين
من الواضح انه لم يكن لديه اي صدى حاليا
هذا يظهر ضعف الموقف الامريكي داخل
السودان لدينا اعلى دبلوماسي اي وزير
الخارجيه بلاينكن الذي يوجه تقريبا نداء
يوميا للجنرال البرهان والجنرال الحميتي
بدون اي تقدم اعتقد ان كل منهما قال له
انهما سيوافقان على وقف لاطلاق النار كما
يفعلان مع بعضهما ومع العالم يقولان شيئا
وفعلا شيئا اخر اذا التحدي الذي تواجهه
واشنطن الان هو انه لا يمكن الوثوق باي
منهما كل ينفذ استراتيجيته من اجل ان يدمر
الاخر
مع ان كل منهما مستعد لتلقي اتصالات من
الاسره الدوليه ولكن يجب ان نشكك في
فعاليات هذا التاثير الذي يمكننا ان نتركه
على كل منهما وبالتالي هذا يعني ان الوضع
خطير جدا لاسيما انا واشنطن تنظر في
احتمال اجلاء مواطنها وحتى مواطننا اخرين
اذا كنا فعلا نريد ان نعتمد على كل من
هذين الجنرلين من اجل ميني الخروج الامن
العاملين الدوليين او للسودانيين الذين
يحاولون الهروب هذا يعتبر مقترحا خطيرا ان
نسلم رقابنا لهذين الجنرالين علما ان كل
منهما يوما بعد الاخر يكسر هذه الثقه التي
بناها مع الاسره الدوليه والولايات
المتحده الوضع صعب جدا وبالتالي يجب ان
نبدا باتخاذ خيارات صعبه لامننا وسلامتنا
ولن نت مكن من الاعتماد على وعد او تعهد
من اي من هذين
جنرالدي في الكاميرون
مدير مركز جنيف الامن والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا اهلا وسهلا بك
الاليه الثلاثيه وغيرها ايضا عملت لوقف
اطلاق النار السيد
اندلي الى اين وصلت ومن الذي من رد الذي
تلقاه الافارقه بهذا الصدد
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان الرد لم يكن ايجابيا للغايه
اعتقد انه يجب ان ناخذ بعين الاعتبار
الظروف المختلفه في السودان والجهود التي
جرت في خلال هذا القتال الذي دار لسبعه
ايام الان هناك قتال كبير بين قوات الدعم
السريع بنجها
والقوات قوات المسلحه السودانيه
وكلى الطرفين يتمسكان بموقفهما ويحاولان
ان يعززاء السيطره ونفوذ على البنى
التحتيه الحيويه وهنا نتحدث عن القصر
الرئاسي واذاعه السودانيه والمطار
والمقر العام للقياده للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه وبالتالي كلا الطرفين يحاولان
ان يعززاه موقفهما وبالتالي هذا الحديث عن
وقف لاطلاق النار هذا لا يزال مجرد حديث
ونحن لم نرى اي ترجمه لذلك بشكل عملي في
الميدان وبالتالي اعتقد اننا ننتظر لنرى
النتيجه النهائيه لهذا القتال سيدي عبد
الحميد صيام ولكن ما الذي يمكن فعله
بشكل عملي يؤدي الى نتيجه عند الحديث عن
ان هذه الجهه او ذاك تعرب عن قلقها اي شخص
انا وانت يمكن ان نعرب عن قلقنا او ان
ندعو لهدنا ولكن ما الفرق بين هذا وان
تكون هناك دول عظمى وامم متحده وجهات
دوليه ما الذي يمكن فعله عمليا لاحراز
نتيجه حقيقيه
يعني حقيقه للامم المتحده مكبله الايدي
وقد فقدت ثلاثه من موظفيها في برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي والان اوضاع الموظفين
هناك وعددهم حوالي ثلاثه الاف موظف اممي
بين موظف دولي وموظف محلي يعمل مع الامم
المتحده اياديهم مكبله تماما وهم يلتزمون
البيوت خاصه ويعملون من بيوتهم الان قد تم
نهب المستودعات قد تم الاعتداء على سيارات
الامم المتحده وعلى مواقعها ولذلك اصبحت
التحرك الامم المتحده في الميدان صعبا
وغير امن لكن ماذا يمكن للامم المتحده ان
تعمل دون ان يكون هناك تعاون دولي وخاصه
من الدول المؤثره هناك الدول تدعم الاطراف
المتقاتله هناك كميات سلاح كشف عنها في
اليومين السابقين غير معهوده اي انه كان
هناك عمليه تخزين
واستعداد لهذا منذ ان بدات المح بين
المكونين العسكريين فيما سمي المجلس
الامني الذي انبثق عن الاتفاقيه الايطاليه
التي تم التوصل اليها في ديسمبر 2022 وكان
هناك خارطه طريق وقد كان السيد فولكر بيرث
متفائلا في اخر تقرير له لمجلس الامن في
العشرين من اذار مارس الماضي لكن عندما
بدات المفاوضات داخل المكون العسكري فيما
سمي باللقاء الامني لحل القضايا وكان هناك
الحديث حول الدمج قوات الدعم السريع في
الجيش هناك بدات الخلافات اي بدا استعداد
من احد الاطراف او من الطرفين لحسم
المعركه عسكريه عندما لم يتفق داخل
اللقاءات التي تمت في
لقاءات التشاوريه حول الوضع الامني الان
هناك دول مؤثره وهناك اتصالات يعني
اتصالات استطاعت مصر ان تخرج قواتها حوالي
عسكريا من السودان هناك ايضا اتصالات بين
بعض الدول الخليجيه
والمكونين هناك دول كذلك روسيا لها علاقه
علاقه
بالسيد حميد زار روسيا وتعرفون انه بقي في
روسيا حوالي تسعه ايام يعني زياره طويله
وبنيت علاقات بين دينكلو محمد حمدان دقلو
حميدتي والاتحاد الروسي هذه الدول مؤثره
يجب ان تتحرك معا لفرض وقفه اطلاق النار
اما اذا كان هناك فقط يعني اتصالات
ومناشدات ورجاء فهذا لن يجدي الا اذا كان
هناك تدخل حقيقي من الدول صاحبه النفوذ
الحقيقي داخل وبلا شك من الدول التي يفترض
انها من صاحب من اصحاب النفود الولايات
المتحده سيد هاتسون فعلى ماذا تقوم
مشاوراتها مع حلفائها وهل يمكن ان ان يكون
هناك اثر لفرض عقوبات تفكر فيها الولايات
المتحده على طرفي الصراع يمكن ان تؤدي في
نهايه المطاف الى وقف هذا الاقتتال
اعتقد انه حصلت نقاشات مؤخرا في واشنطن
حول العقوبات العقوبات على العسكر وعلى
قوات الدعم السريع نحن نعرف انه خلال
حقبه
سابقه من العنف التي الذي مارست قوه
الدعاء السريع والانقلاب الذي قاده
البرهان السنه الماضيه تم تحضير العقوبات
ولم تنفذ هذه العقوبات لا تزال متاحه
واعتقد ان هناك نقاش ناشط داخل الاوساط
السياسيه داخل اداره بايدن في واشنطن حول
ما اذا كان الوقت ملائما الان من اجل فرد
هذه العقوبات
اعتقد ان هذه العقوبات كان يجب ان تفرض
منذ فتره
كان يجب ان يتعرض حماتي للعقوبات في يونيو
حين قام بالتعرض
للحركه المدنيه امام المقر العسكري وقتل
كثيرين نعرف انه كان مسؤولا عن عمل العنف
بمساعده حلفاء الروس
وبالتالي وجاب
مسائلاته منذ ان حصل ذلك في سياق نفسه
وجابت معاقبه البرهان على الانقلاب الذي
قاده ولكن بما اننا لم نفرض عقوبات عليهما
بقي
ناشطين سياسيا في البلاد
ودفع البلاد الى مسار الحرب الذي تعيشه
اليوم اذا هما يستحقان العقوبات في الوقت
نفسه اخشى اننا اذا اخترنا فرض عقوبات
عليهما نعطيهما فرصه للاستمرار في القتال
ان اولوياتنا تقضي بان نوقف القتال نفرض
وقت اطلاق النار ونبدا النقاش والحوار
السياسي مع ان العقوبات مستحقه الان
ولكنها قد ترتد علينا على المدى القصير
ولا تساعدنا وبالتالي يجب ان لا نذير وسعا
الان من اجل ان نحقق استراحه انصح القول
انقاذ الناس انقاذ الارواح وما نرى من
الطرفين هو انهما مهتمان
تدمير احد اهمال الاخر اكثر من حمايه
المدنيين العالقين في الوسط وبالتالي لا
يمكننا ان نفعل شيئا الان يعطيه ما سببا
اضافيا للاستمرار بالقتال حتى الموت سيد
كيف تبدو لك العلاقه بين الحراك
الدبلوماسيه الغربي وما يقوم به الاتحاد
الافريقي على سبيل المثال وهل توجد هناك
اوراق ضغط حقيقيه يمكن ان تؤثر على
الطرفين وتؤدي الى نتيجه عمليه
في الحقيقه اعتقد ان الامر في غايه
الصعوبه
يصعب استخدام اي اوراق الضغط في هذه
الفتره وتحدث زميلي الضيف الاخر عن
العقوبات العقوبات التي يمكن ان تفرض على
القياده في الجانبين انا من وجهه نظري لا
اعتقد ان العقوبات سوف تجدي نفعا حتى اذا
ما تحدثنا على الامد القصير في الامد
القصير يصعب ان نرى ان
الجانبين سوف يتوقفان عن القتال قبل تحقيق
المكاسب اذا ما اضفنا التدخلات
الخارجيه لكلا الجانبين دعما لهذا الجانب
او ذاك هذا ما يزيد من تعقيد المشهد هناك
محاوله
لترسيخ النفوذ في السودان ولذلك لن اي
منهما على وقف لاطلاق النار في الفتره
الراهنه لان من شان ذلك ان يعطي الفرصه
للطرف الاخر لكي يرسخ النفوذ ويعزز سلطته
في المناطق التي تم السيطره عليها
وبالتالي هذه هي المشكله التي يعاني منها
السودان الان هناك حديث عن امكانيه ارسال
قوات
للسلام لفرض السلام او احلال السلام في
البلاد وتشكل الفصل بين المنطقتين وبين
الطرفين المتقاتلين ولكننا لنا زال نتحدث
عن افكار مجرد افكار حيث انه من الصعب ومن
الخطر ان يتم نشر اي قوات اجنبيه وحياه اي
من الاشخاص المتواجدين في الميدان معرضه
للخطر اذا سوف يحاول الرجلان
يستمر في هذه العمليه وبالتالي نحن نتحدث
عن وضع فيه الكثير من التحديات للاتحاد
الافريقي والبلدان الجاره للسودان
وللولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك فقط
دعوه لكلا الطرفين لاحترام وقف اطلاق
النار نعم هناك دعوات مستمره السيد عبد
الحميد صيامه لا تعتبر الامم المتحده هي
المظله الاوسع هل تعتقد انه يعني يمكن ان
يكون هناك عمل دبلوماسي في اروقه الامم
المتحده لجمع الجهود وان تكون هناك اليه
معينه جمع جهود اطراف الحقيقه مصالحها
مختلفه
للاسهام في وقت في وقف الاحتراب السوداني
السوداني
يعني ما زالت الامم المتحده هي الطرف
الوحيد الذي يستطيع ان يتصل بالطرفين من
داخل السودان وليس من خارجه فقط وبالتالي
جمع الامين العام جهودا كبرى يوم الخميس
الماضي في اجتماع مغلق ثم اتصل بالاطراف
وجميعها لكن ما زالت الطرفين
ان يعتقدان انهما سيحسم المعركه عسكريه
يعني يذكروني هذا بقول الشاعر ابن المعتز
انما قال كالنار تاكل بعضها ان لم تجد ما
تاكله هذان الطرفان كان متحالفين ضد
المكون المدني وقام بالانقلاب انقلاب 25
اكتوبر 2021 معا
وابقصي المكون المدني والان ياكلان بعضهما
بعضا الخوف هو انه قد تتوسع هذه
الاشتباكات وتتحول الى حرب اهليه خاصه ان
الديكلوي يمثل الغرب السوداني وان عبد
الفتاح البرهان يمثل الشمال السوداني
وبالتالي قد قلب الى حرب اهليه اوسع لذلك
انا في وجهه نظري ان الطرف الاكثر تاهيلا
لوقف هذه الحرب هو الشعب السوداني بان
يخرجوا كما خرجوا ضد عمر البشير واجبروا
المكون العسكري ان يتخلص من عمر البشير
ربما يكون هذا الوضع الاسلم ان تكون هناك
حركات جماهيريه كبيره لفرد وقفه اطلاق
النار ولكن يعني سيد عبد الحميد صيامه
للشعب السوداني الان لا يستطيع الذهاب حتى
ليشتري علبه حليب اطفال من
البقاله او شيء دواء مهم من الصيدليه وقت
هذا
وسط هذه المعارك الضارة التي تدور في في
شوارع العاصمه
هذا صحيح خاصه في العاصمه لكن هناك 45
مليون سوداني الان ممكن ان يضج هذا الشعب
وهناك انا قرات صباحا ان هناك تحرك مدني
كبير في مناطق دارفور وفي مناطق اخرى
لتحاول ان تتحرك بهذا الاتجاه لان هناك
طرفان يريد كل منهما ان يفني الاخر يعني
تفانا ودقوا بينهم عطره منشن يعني اما يجب
ان ينهى الاخر فما الحل المجتمع الدولي
يناشد ولكن ليس لديه اي وسائل حقيقيه
ليفرض وقف اطلاق النار حتى ولا العقوبات
العقوبات تاتي في فتره يعني نوع من
الازمات في ايام الهدنه لكن حاليا في
القتال يجب ان يكون هناك وقف للقتال من هي
القوه التي تستطيع ان تفرض وقف القتال اذا
كانت هذه القوه من الخارج غير متوفره الان
ولا يوجد استعداد من اي جهه ان ترسل
قواتها والامم المتحده الان كما قلت لا
تستطيع ان تتحرك لايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه فما العمل نعم يترك هذا من
الطرفان ليفني بعضهما بعضا ويدفع الشعب
السوداني الثمن في رايي انه ممكن ان يكون
هناك تحرك على مستوى الشارع والشعب
السوداني
السيد كامل
الوزير بلينك الوزير الخارجيه
طالب مره اخرى البرهان وحمايه الالتزام
بوقف اطلاق النار وايضا هناك حديث الان ان
البنتاجون سينشر قوات
للتعامل مع حالات الطوارئ قرب السودان ما
الذي يمكن ان نفهمه من هذا بالتحديد
مره اخرى ان
المحادثات بالنسبه الى نشر القوات
الامريكيه الى السودان محدوده ومقتصره على
انقاذ طاقم السفاره الامريكيه واخراجه من
البلاد لا نتحدث ولم يعج ري اي نقاش عن
الجيش الامريكي
وانخراط بطريقه ناشطه في المواجهات
والقتال
في السودان انا لا اعتقد ان هذا موضوع سوف
يتم نقاشه حاليا اعتقد ان تركيز واشنطن هو
من اجل منع الاخرين من المشاركه في هذا
النزاع
لقد راينا بعد التقارير الاوليه ان
ميليشيا حفتر في ليبيا قد شاركت ثمان ايضا
تقارير
محتمله عن متمردين من جمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى
دعونا لا ننسى ان قوات الدعم السريع هي
ميليشيا في الاساس هي مجموعه متمرده بطرق
مختلفه هذا هو اصلها بالتالي لا يجوز ان
ننسى انها سوف تحاول التواصل مع مجموعات
متمرده اخرى مع ميليشيات اخرى في دول
مجاوره وكل الدول المجاوره من ليبيا الى
تشاد الى افريقيا الوسطى الى اثيوبيا
البرهان والجنرالات في الجيش هل هل يتم
النظر للطرفين بنفس النظره ام كيف
هذا ما تقصده اذا بالنسبه الى النظره
اليها في واشنطن اعتقد ان المشكله حين
ننظر الى الاتفاق الايطالي من ديسمبر
العام الماضي الذي ساعدت واشنطن على
صياغته
هذا الاتفاق الايطالي يجعل الطرفين في هذا
النزاع على قدم المساواه
لم يكن
يتوجب علينا معاملتهما على قدم المساواه
ولكن هذا الاتفاق الايطالي عملهما على
انهما طرفان
على قدم المساواه وهذا احد اخطاء هذا
الاتفاق لانه قد اغضب المتحفظين داخل
الجيش
وصعب كيفيه
تصور ادماج قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش
حين يكون لدينا عناصر اسلاميه
متحفظه تتصدى لها هذا هو خطا الاتفاق لا
اعتقد ان واشنطن قصادت ان هذا الخطا ولم
تشا فعلا ان ترفع من منصب القوات الدعم
السريع ولكن بعدم معاقبه هذه القوات او
هؤلاء الاشخاص زدنا من مشروعيته السياسيه
سامحنا لشخص مثل حماتي
ان يحاول تلميع صورته وسمعتي ويقدم نفسه
على انه سياسي ماداني وهذا ما كان يسعى
اليه ونحن لم نحاسبه ولم نساله على جرائمه
السابقه ومن خلال عدم القيام بذلك اعتقد
اننا عاملنا هذين الشخصين على انه
النقطه لم واريد ان اسال السيد زيد منطقه
العقوبات التي تفكر فيها الولايات المتحده
باختصار من فضلك هل يتماشى مع الجهود
الافريقيه وهل تعتقد انه حل فاعل
في الحقيقه لا اعتقد ان العقوبات سوف تكون
بالحل الفاعل في هذه المرحله كما سبق
واسلفنا لان العقوبات بحاجه الى وقت لكي
نرى المفاعيل الخاصه بهذه العقوبات في
الميدان وبالتالي هناك قتال يجري الان بين
الطرفين وهذا القتال يستمر وطرفان لا
يصغيان الى الدعوات الخارجيه سواء كنا
نتحدث عن قوات الدعم السريع او
الجيش بقياده البرهان في العام 2019 كانت
الوسطات فعاله ولكن
الوقت للاسف اود ان اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
في الكاميرون وكاميرون السابق للرئيس
اوباما الى السودان من من واشنطن ومن
نيويورك عبد الحميد صيام الخبير في شؤون
الامم المتحده
ومشاهدينا بهذا ناتي الى نهايه هذه الحلقه
من ما وراء الخبر
[موسيقى]